welcome back to New Rockstars it's me MD
and with Madame Webb being Sony Pictures
first major spider title after
Spider-Man no way home cracked open the
door to the Multiverse in the MCU
everybody has been wondering just what
the plans for Sony cinematic spider
verse even are especially after the
post-credits scene of morbius caused us
all to briefly question our own sanity
when Michael Keaton's vulture appeared
to disappear from the MCU into a much
less cooler Universe like what the hell
was that even about anyway wow my nerd
babies I can't believe I'm saying this
but I think the post-credits scene of
morbius actually makes sense
well let's talk about it by nerd babies
because I have a feeling that the events
of Spider-Man no way home just started a
whole mess of [ __ ] for everybody in the
spider-verse it could leave our MCU
Peter with some unexpected Multiverse
villains to deal with in Spider-Man 4 or
Beyond but before we get into that make
sure to head on over to new
rockstarsbarch.com today to pick up our
new latest Obsession shirts and also all
of our amazing nerd gear over on that
site we have a bunch of spectacular nerd
stuff just for you or somebody that you
love at new rockstarsmerch.com today
alright so here's the deal y'all Peter
Parker and doctor strange that messed up
the entire damn spider verse and no way
home and Madam Webb is probably going to
be the first one tasked with fixing
their mess but before we get into how
they did that let's talk about Madame
Webb because Madam Webb is of course set
to Star Dakota Johnson as The titular
[Music]
because Madam Webb is of course at the
star Dakota Johnson as Madam Webb Julia
Carpenter Madame Webb to be exact from
the looks of Dakota Johnson's where
Julia Carpenter's iconic red jacket in
some of the behind the scenes images
that we've seen from the set so far and
if you know anything about that
character from the comics you'll know
that whoever has the title of Madame
Webb possesses the unique ability to see
the fates of anybody tied to a little
something called the web of life and
Destiny which is basically the cosmic
thread that is the source of the powers
of every single spider person as they
are all connected to this web as Spider
avatars in particular it's the direct
source of every spider person's Spider
Sense which has allowed all of our
favorite Spider-Man to have a slice of
cosmic precognition not only giving them
the ability to find other spider people
connected to the great web but also the
majorly helpful ability to perceive
future dangers that are headed their way
to an insane degree like the fact that
MCU Peter Parker could detect the black
order's arrival in Infinity War the
Green Goblins imminent betrayal in
Norway home just proves that his powers
are more than just science based like
there's some crazy Supernatural [ __ ]
going on here in that Supernatural
element being spider people this
precognitive information in the form of
a spider says and we sort of see that
happening when Doctor Strange pushes
Peter into his astral form in Spider-Man
no way home as Peter's unconscious body
is playing keep away with Doctor Strange
we can see Peter's spider-sense
squigglies over his astral body like
these little transparent squigglies this
is what I believe to be Marvel studios's
way of showing us Spider-Man's
connection to the Web of Life and
Destiny and it is this very connection
to the great web that Madame Webb gets
her incredible precognitive powers from
as well as her ability to detect spider
avatars and assemble them Nick Fury
style despite Madame Webb's blindness
but this will also likely mean that
Madame Webb will be one of the first to
spider avatars in the spider-verse to
realize just how much 616 Peter Parker
and Doctor Strange mess up the entire
Web of Life and Destiny because she has
the strongest link to it hey you yeah
I'm talking to you I know by virtue of
the fact that you're here that you are a
fan of new rock stars but you're more
than that too you've got your own hot
takes while theories and of course you
know what's cool right [ __ ] now if
you really want to show off how much of
a new Rockstar you are yourself then all
you got to do to join the team is
support the Channel with some new
rockstars gear from epicurershop.com and
let me tell you this the new gear is
here we've got all new enamel pins but
they're limited edition these
Collectibles are numbered one to five
hundred and once they sell out they are
gone forever but maybe you don't want
pins maybe you want some crop tops well
we got those too I know what he's very
excited about those crop tops and if
you're not in SoCal like me and have to
deal with all this cold weather [ __ ]
then we've got a special hoodie to show
off that you know what the internet
cares about right now and if you're not
in a cold climate we've got some sweet
mineral wash distressed teas and
oversized teas to boot and once you're
all decked out grab a blue screen and a
wild theory about what's gonna happen in
Phase 10 and you're basically just you
know doing my job so if you want to just
take my job just head on The Epicure
shop.com please don't take my job
snagging submerged from epicurershop.com
is the absolute best way to support the
channel in wearing that merch is the
best way to spot fans of the wild so
make sure you wear it to screenings
parties or while sneaking into our
office to join the last bag of Funyuns
your Funyuns are mine Brandon
recreate those iconic shots and tag at
epic hero shop to get featured on their
page get everything that you need to be
the stylish nerd that you know that you
are at epiceroshop.com y'all know how
the saying goes what a tangled web we
weave when we practice to deceive and
that goes double when you're trying to
deceive the entire planet into
forgetting that Peter Parker is
Spider-Man because here's the problem
gang because Peter won Peter 2 and Peter
3 refuse to leave the villains of no way
home to their respective Fates in order
to save the villains lives they had to
alter their Destinies like Doc Ock
Electro and Green Goblin were all
supposed to die because we saw them die
in their respective movies that was the
original Destiny the web of life and
Destiny had for these lives however by
changing those lives and destinies the
web of life for Destiny got tangled as
[ __ ] changing the Destinies of a bunch
of people who knew that Peter Parker was
Spider-Man throughout the entire spider
verse like some type of weird Cosmic
Lottery which is why MCU vulture was
sent to the wrong Universe vulture knew
from the end of Spider-Man homecoming
that Peter Parker was Spider-Man so
since the web of life and Destiny got
all tangled up because all the Peters
switched some Destinies up the web of
life and Destiny twisted and changed
vulture's Destiny sending him to the
morbius universe where the food is
significantly less better this being
said if this is the case we could see a
major spider-verse problem that could
potentially bleed into the MCU as well
because of people who know that Peter
Parker as Spider-Man are being sent to
different universes as a result of the
tangling of the web and life in Destiny
um your boy Tom Holland potentially got
some problems headed his way in the form
of both Dane to Hans Harry Osborne and
Topher Grace's Venom because I'm not
sure if you guys remember but both of
those guys pretty much immediately
wanted to kill Spider-Man when they
found out his identity so if Peter and
Doctor Strange somehow altered their
Fates in no way home there is a chance
here that both Harry Osborne and Eddie
Brock have been displaced from their
native universes and brought to the MCU
to find Peter or hell maybe one of them
will even appear in Madame Webb and try
to kill the Spider-Man of that Universe
because we do know that Madam Webb
appears to be set in the universe nearly
similar to that of Sam raimi's
Spider-Man universe with an early 2000s
Vibe so it would be super interesting to
see Dame de Hans Harry Osborne try to
kill Toby Maguire Spider-Man when Toby
Maguire's Spider-Man was just a baby I
think that'd be a really fun way to
continue that villain's story without
actually having to confirm an Amazing
Spider-Man 3 just yet but either way
this is what I believe Sony's plans are
for Madame Webb and the weird ass ending
of morbius I think that they have really
interesting plans to switch the villains
up and like just tangle up the web of
life and Destiny in the MCU and Beyond I
guess but only time will tell thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at Master attainment on
Twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] but most importantly you can
follow the rock stars whatever the rock
stars are I'm the social media videos on
the internet but again thank you guys so
much for spending time with me and
watching this video I love you guys
times a million bajillion and I'll see
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]